[Applause]
aka the sniper aka the main event big
men singing i've seen a few people in
the comments asking for me to come back
so men's come through baby get me i'm
going to be grilling her are you looking
for a relationship
sniper out now on all digital platforms
rev if you aren't aware sniper is his
new song
hi
what's your name cheyenne
the older mixed race girl name is this
nice okay yo she's kind of cris still
you get me a nice little light skin tin
curly hair you get me she's a slim ting
you get me but one two three stone it's
perfect but i could feed her you get me
[Laughter]
if you don't know what stones are that's
the unit of uh weight that they have
over there yeah okay yes
yeah they didn't like scales so they
just put rocks on top of each other
that's it [ __ ] you you as big as these
three boulders
you want some more fish and chips yeah
it took you a while to get here wherever
you been
what it wasn't [ __ ] this morning then
last night don't know no lie
so you've
had sex with someone and came straight
here yeah have you cleaned your dave of
course can't be walking i have fresh
[ __ ] on my breath that's rude you know
i got a [ __ ] on my breath
did you actually yeah i did for real and
bother you bothers me a bit wider you
could have taken one to willy's last
night again it's not my business this is
what i'm saying this is why it's scary
and this is why i don't like dating
because i just feel like everyone's just
moving mad don't worry though i'm fully
drained right now so you know it's a
genuine thing right now i'm actually
trying to get to know you
this man
i'm fully drained right now i'm empty so
you know i'm gonna be continuing
you know it's not gonna be the
testosterone talking see nah nah nah i
saw a gap in the market blood
this man basically said you ain't got
dick goggles on so uh are you trying to
get this let's go let's talk what's your
thoughts on like toxic masculinity what
the [ __ ] is that big man saying i don't
even know what that hyper masculinity
thing is bro but shout out to my lgbtq
people wherever you get me this is it
lgbtq he's a lgbtq
what the heck
what the hell i don't know what he's
very sad oh you got a little bit of
toxic masculinity i don't know what hype
and masculinity is man shout out to
lgbtq community
you name three things
let's go you get me listen i don't know
anything about physics but you know
shout out to black people
that's what
happened but you know what this man's a
little too honest how many people do
that live
enough
like over 100
sniper out now on all digital platforms
so back in the day yeah let's say i've
seen like a few things i had a few
things on rotation yeah what i do i see
one in the morning yeah so like let's
say not in the morning like 12 o'clock
lunch time yeah she come through yeah
then fight then she's going around five
o'clock i got my next thing five o'clock
one would leave around nine yeah and
then i get my next income for around 12.
no you're actually disgusting around 12
yeah and then in the morning i'd say
like yo guys i go i gotta go work them
times i don't even have a [ __ ] job
breath forget me but i'd say you're
basically get i gotta go work yeah i put
on my clothes everything like i'm going
work yeah why don't you say can you
leave because i'm not a horrible bastard
brother that's that's terrible how could
i just tell them to leave like that
that's mad no the only time that you got
a goal is if like you're a crazy [ __ ]
brother if you're crazy you've got to
leave my house i mean one time i see a
girl it's like he must have beat fell
asleep four o'clock in the morning she
woke up said she want pizza because she
asked looks like normal four in the
morning right i'm hungry what's
happening there's no pizza shops open at
that time the only people out is
crackheads bev
this guy's too honest
hey
the thing and he said it the thing empty
so you're going to imagine your girl
waking up at 4 30. i'm going out to get
pizza crackers
are you on crack
cracker
cracker i don't even know what to say
man this man is just saying everything
he's thinking you can tell she's really
taken aback by how honestly
no but this guy was just [ __ ] before
he's not he's not trying to win her no
this guy's just there yeah i'm just here
so i don't get fined yes do you want
love
out of now on all digital platforms rev
why have you got gold teeth because my
teeth are [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
this is bad yeah i'm honest this man's
killing me
why you got grown grills because my
teeth are [ __ ] up bro
snap out on digital platforms
i was raising the caribbean i didn't go
to no dentist so nothing by the time i
come back up here my teeth was just do
you not want love snipe out now on all
digital platforms
he's out here promoting his [ __ ] hey and
being here so we don't get fine hey if
you guys aren't aware sniper out on
digital platforms bruh guys did you know
that sniper out on our digital platform
i'm putting a link in the description
because this man's advertised it so much
go check out the sniper so it's not leo
sniper is out on our digital platform
what do you want out of life i want peas
with yeah i want money that's what i
want you want just money yeah they loved
him money is one so you don't want love
no no no because your heart's been
broken yeah a few times a few times
do you feel like you've been burned so
many times you're just not on it now do
you know what it is here i'm length and
yell down thing right now brother i'm
not gonna lie it's just about laying
down the girl then right now but if i
just feel like rather this willie's
gotta be shared but i just got a link
down the go
that dick is not going anywhere near me
this is not a date this is an interview
he's just answering questions he's not
trying to win nobody over
i'm on a legging down
facebook something must have hollered at
me on there i met up with him so we went
to her yard we and as soon as we
finished
she started smoking crack breath what
yeah she started smoking correctly so
you said with crackhead basically
this guy
doesn't care about how he comes across
basically yeah it's a crackhead like i
didn't know she was a crackhead at the
time but the [ __ ] was good you get me
but you look like you're like bad man
yeah you like you're like a to let's
grab you by the throat and just mash up
your thing i'm not gonna lie
grab you by the hair mash up your thing
you need to mash it up your ear yeah
you need to
i got nothing to say so you never had a
night with somebody bear back i know
you're funny
you ever got sti before so you never had
chlamydia no i caught it like four times
in the past i was [ __ ] two
ask you bro
she didn't ask you
the amount of times he has sex i'm not
surprised he's actually media what
advice do you give guys to get laid it's
three things yeah
number one look presentable
yeah you get me go get yourself a decent
haircut if you're a fat bastard go gym
some men can't pull it off you get me
yeah that's number one get your
appearance down you get me you don't
want to be scared enough to kill them
yeah number two be confident about your
[ __ ] it don't matter if you're broke
don't matter if like you're a top waist
man you can make it work a lot of men
that are super waste man they get yelled
you just need a bit of confidence yeah
and number three don't overthink the
thing yeah a lot of men think that
chatting to a girl is a big thing like
approaching a girl is a big thing you
just gotta look at it like this don't go
in there with no motives even trying to
go in there to get [ __ ] and matting
just go on there on some get to know the
person thing and everything will fall
into place it's when you try and force
it and try and have an objective try and
have a motive try and have some sort of
end goal you're going to show your card
straight away gal is going to see
through that so you're trying to get
[ __ ] so you ain't got no confidence and
it's gone yeah strike up a regular
conversation if you get rejected
there's big yell out here it's not that
deep that's pretty good advice yo that's
pretty good advice especially the third
thing what do you say about like not
having motive i think guys go in with
such an end goal in my life i need to
get ready to read that people read it
later
you know like if you're someone who
can't even talk to people just go up to
talk to women and men and just have a
regular conversation motherfucker's too
needy to walk away without asking for
anything as you get more comfortable by
doing that then afterwards escalating to
something more is a lot easier and much
more natural but a lot of [ __ ]
go into conversations and start acting
outside of yourself because you want to
end goal and we all know it's weird it's
like when a guy comes up to you and
tries to sell you on his like latest
product you feel uncomfortable because
you can feel like they want to sell you
on something don't try to sell yourself
and i think that's what a lot of people
do you reckon you ever will just sit
with just one woman and not she be with
her
on all digital platforms i hate honestly
i hate you it's so hard to have a
conversation with so i'm going to take
it as a no
no on all digital platforms
i feel like this is a front and this is
why you've got your glasses on and i
think that it's like an insecurity thing
in the nicest way
you have
good intentions but you just choose not
to and it's a shame and that's why i'm
not falling for that bad boy storyline
that i could make you change you're just
toxic business [ __ ] pigmenting cheers to
the toxicity and that don't know
no [ __ ] give it do you think i'm toxic
actually thinks she is about trisha
goddard in that rap she thinks he's a
therapist long what if my ex was after
you if it's over gio he needs to [ __ ]
off but if he's got a personal problem
with me i'd have to mash him up but if
it's over you i'm beefing over you with
why what if we were together nine beef
another guy that's dead can't beef over
yeah i'd have a problem with him coming
to me not with you because i'm not
beefing over gal but on a man level if
he crosses like if he's trying to cross
that line i have to mash him up that's
man i agree
that's it
yo he said i'm not beefing over yeah i'm
not beefing over yet either i'm not
doing it
nah nah just because man see a gap in
the market blood trying to move up on me
huh i'm not i'm not beefing over yellow
he's being consistent yeah i appreciate
it yeah even if you guys think like what
a weirdo whatever he is who he is and
he's comfortable and who is but i agree
with the principle of not fighting over
women you know what i'm saying that
that's stupid that's not alpha abba now
obviously if i'm out with my girl right
and some do try to then that's a
different story what if i genuinely want
to involve other people in our sex life
if it's another cool if you try to bring
mandom in there it's a whole another mad
thing that now you're just violating me
on next level now i gotta watch next man
[ __ ] the shirt of you while i'm there in
the back just watching like a victim rev
what is the problem with having a man so
man's gonna be drilling you out and i'm
like looking at man's ball bags clapping
off your bum cheeks that's mad
best man
if it's another girl it's cool but the
girl has to be on your level you get me
you can't be bringing those super fat
[ __ ] built like a snowman to me but
it's dead i like big things if you're
built like a snowman it's there's
there's fig i like big and curvy super
big and curvy you could be 16 17 18
stone and curvy but if you're built like
a like a raspberry it's not happening
it's poetry
this [ __ ] is a poet
can't just be out here built like a
minion breath
[Laughter]
that's bad
depression in that i feel like to be
fair i've been depressed for a long time
it's social media that saved my life
yeah i was going for a [ __ ] time yeah i
made one social media video went viral
that should change my life but to be
fair
the cure to depression is to figuring
out the root of it my root was being
broke yeah i figured out the root of it
and then that's it but along the way i
had to learn a lot of [ __ ] about myself
what did you learn about yourself you
learn your resilience you learn how
strong you are you learn how to stretch
peace you learn to be [ __ ] on and be
able to come back from that you know to
fall down seven times and stand up eight
times you learn all of that you get me
you learn that rejection all of that
[ __ ] is nothing rejection is normal
failing is normal yeah i'm trying to say
like i gotta give a shout to the people
which is like followers on instagram
people say that i don't mean nothing but
for me then people changed my life like
100 then people lifted me out of all
that [ __ ] yeah because if they didn't
help me i'd be on a mad thing because i
was this close to murking people but i
used to sit on night buses all day i'd
set on night buses in the night so i
want to go insane to keep my peace of
mind yeah i'm trying to say and like if
anybody owed me money or nothing i would
probably do the worst to you yeah i'm
gonna say a few times i try to set
people up just because they try and do
something bad to me it's not a joke
thing this depression thing will make
you
find depths of yourselves that you've
never ever find in your life yeah i'm
trying to say and when you come out from
that though you become a better person
there's nothing wrong with being in a
[ __ ] bro everybody got to lose their
mind once because then when you find
yourself it's a madness but it's
beautiful you get me that's why i'm
happy all the time now but life is
beautiful i like that to you
how do you think you've done on the date
i don't really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie about
[Applause]
it
this [ __ ] doesn't give a [ __ ] no
and that's what i said this guy is not
on the date he's on an interview ask me
a question i answered him i'm not here
to win you over cause i already had
[ __ ] and i have [ __ ] on my breasts
right now
i can smell it on my breath
taste it but but that's wrap it back
yeah it gotta be like listen don't build
these attachments to people you just met
people get attached to outcomes that's
why man yo i've taken these big old l's
that have moved on and i've told you
stories about else i've taken and it's
like it's not that deep for me it's just
a funny story afterwards you got to be
able to walk away so someone's like man
how do you think i did i don't really
give a [ __ ] i i presented me who are you
to judge me afterwards here's the thing
right i can only present me you get me
afterwards either you're in or you're
not and if you're not that's cool i'm
not even mad at you how much you think
but i can't do anything other than
present me so if i presented me and you
don't [ __ ] then you was never gonna [ __ ]
with me anyway so why would i be
concerned with the outcome all you can
do is
put your foot forward and that's it and
that's how it should be that's this and
that's me
i know that i did good you get me i know
that i'm a spice so
regardless how it goes i don't give too
bad but i'm going to leave there get
some [ __ ] anyway so i had a great time
okay you're getting me how about you you
have a good time that wasn't the right
time no no i like that thank you you get
me
that's it moving on this guy that's it
[ __ ] gem that's it [ __ ] gem and
he's being consistent yeah she thinks
she's a psychologist she's out here
being a therapist like the reason why
you have your glasses some [ __ ]
just like that look
some people need to like being incognito
i can can i admit something to you go
for it
i used to clown these [ __ ] go
people nice
shades in the night the more and more
yeah i like that [ __ ] yeah
shades yeah it's the [ __ ]
daytime
you walk around
you can look a booty unexpected
nobody's suspecting you and not only
that it's just it closes people like you
can be like yo yo you know
being in the sphere
of attention and stuff like that it
closes the like people think they don't
know if you're looking at them if you
you have your shades on
i'm just trying to ignore
i'm trying to ignore you you want to see
my shades
that's how i walk how many times you see
me across town like this why
why it's not because i want to look
special i want to have as little contact
with people sometimes because when
you're on the bottom people recognize
you it's annoying sometimes so you just
try to find ways to kind of hide
yourself away it's the same thing as you
ladies
when you walk and you cross a man let's
say the man is there and he's crossing
you that way what do you do do you look
at the man
no you don't because you don't want that
attention you look away just to tell him
that you're not inter same thing
same thing
shades shout out to him
shout out to that dude hey hey hey
sniper out on all platforms
sniper out on all digital platforms bro
sniper out on all digital platform for
not honestly like brev just say it
sniper are on all digital platform buff
big things
man saw gap in the market blood and let
me tell you
sniper out on digital platforms bruh
yeah you don't know you get
not something madness something
mad things
honestly like
i came through
no honestly like i came through i told
mine
you're moving you're moving you know
what are you dizzy you know what
it's you bro yeah that's my favorite
line now man saw gap in the market blood
that's a mind
yeah that's a good one that's a good
[ __ ] all right that's been that's right
thing
is a caribbean thing here but enough
people from the caribbean are in the uk
here
boom
the road to road map initiative yeah
you know what that is no the road to
roman issues
road man road to road man initiative i
don't don't know it sounds like
something that uh what's his name
um
the rapper
what's his [ __ ] name
i think
roadman anyways whatever
you listen to uk drills
millions
check millions bags all right leave your
comments below tell us if you should
check that out regular bags
regular bag